originally owned by the daughter of
Marie Antoinette's governess this
chateau is a trove of hidden
architectural gems about 30 miles
outside of Paris stands chateau de
Grasse built in 1815 it remained a
family home until the 1930s when it was
bought by an Italian arts patron who
made modifications including
chinese-inspired gardens the Tartar tent
and a theatre the private mini theater
of chateau de Grasse opened in 1957 and
is inspired by a baroque opera house in
Germany today it is still active with
plays and concerts taking place
throughout the year
one of the chateaus most admired
features is the library it is said that
it was Cecile Payton's inspiration for
the library in the film my fair lady but
the most unusual feature of all is the
Tata
tent a painted metal pavilion but made
to look like a fabric tent the interior
of which features 10,000 Delft tiles the
Chateau was declared a historic monument
in 1993 and is open to the public for
weekend visits or special events a walk
through this Chateau really shows how
the other half lived
[Music]
you
[Music]